hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review got a request to test
power cables and i remembered that i had
bought this audio quest cable for
testing about a year ago
it's the
nrg-x3 uh i think they go to y and
pass that um the version that i bought
is a two meter uh length um and it costs
about a hundred dollars
you can see my uh order from amazon here
um
so as uh aftermarket cables go is quite
inexpensive although you know the free
cable comes with the equipment so
compared to that it's infinitely more
expensive
um
uh the one thing i was uh disappointed
to see for a company size of audioquest
is that there's no certificate
regulatory safety certifications on this
in u.s that would be ul and
it could be the ce or csa regulations
and certification
none of that is on this um so us maybe
you can get away with because ul is not
mandatory but for
europe c certification c
compliance at least is mandatory
otherwise you can't export the product
and i looked on the box even everywhere
i looked on their website there's no
mention whatsoever of anything
related to that the only thing i see on
the cable is actually their own brand
and it only says
oh i guess it does have temperature
rating is 16 gauges and 300 volts 75
degrees c
but uh
you know no certification for the
cabling or termination not looking at it
there's nothing that worries me but you
know those safety standards are there
for a reason
and uh you know you want to have the
peace of mind that something plugs into
electricity uh you know that deals with
high currents and high voltages you know
it doesn't have any safety risks of this
thing for example getting hot and
catching on fire or something of the
sort so
is it gonna happen who knows but you
know my little cheap uh
generic ac cord that i use has ul
listing on both the wire and the end of
it the end terminal it's plugged in down
there i'm not going to get it but
at the you know right even inside here
has a ul stamp on it and it has it on
his wire and it goes way past that and
saying what kind of jacket it has and so
forth so a big miss you know i can see
somebody making cables in their garage
not being able to afford to pay a lab to
do this kind of testing but to see a
company like audioquest that sells
millions of dollars worth of cables
wouldn't have five thousand dollars to
go spend uh
get that regulatory uh uh certification
is it just disappointing
on the positive front the cable itself
is feels better than the generic mains
cable that you get
i don't think it's silicone which is one
of my favorites but much more expensive
but it's something halfway between the
pvc jackets and and silicone as fresh
flexibility feels good
the ends look kind of dorky to me
this thing looks like maybe something
out of 1960s plug for uh
i don't know uh hot water uh
kettle or something
it doesn't look fancy doesn't look
high-end and the whole cable doesn't
look fancy or high and so that's
typically something that you get and
it's sort of an unwritten rule that if
you're going to be in the cable business
you dress up the cable as much as you
can because you know other benefits may
be hard to prove but the look could be
it but anyway
it is what it is so let's move on i was
uh delighted to read the uh
uh
feature list below the feature list on
their website and notice this thing that
says it minimizes distortion i haven't
seen that claim before everybody talks
about what the copper is made out of and
everything but it says minimize
distortion caused by grain boundary that
exists within any metal container
so the nice thing about so i'm delighted
is that you know you talk about
distortion we can measure distortion you
talk about i don't know adds air to your
music that that you know i may not be
able to measure but i sure as i can
measure distortion it also says it uh
gets rid of uh it has noise dissipation
technology whatever that means and uh
uh so but we can test that also so both
of those are quant quantifiable uh
characteristics now what's a little
silly is that uh let's say this thing
does uh have special k material in it
that uh
doesn't add distortion but you know you
got hundreds of feet of cable behind
your socket and then outside your
building that you can't even control
surely if cable adds distortion per foot
then having you know hundreds and and
you know thousands of feet of meters of
this of any generic cable will dwarf
anything that a six-foot cable could add
so the logic of this makes no sense that
this this you know you would care about
this part of it not having distortion um
where you know if every cable has
distortion then
you know any systems you use without
this cable should sound awful which we
know that's not the case but anyway we
take these things at face value uh if we
wanted to reason through this thing we
wouldn't even test it but
you know we want to prove to ourselves
that
that we know uh what the benefits are or
not uh speaking of which i started with
measuring dc resistance these things can
get hooked up to a power amplifier and
we want to know whether they have extra
resistance to flow of uh
electricity in there
and my generic cable which i just
randomly picked had a 0.13 ohm
dc resistance and this one was much
better 0.02 ohm so
about 10 percent 15 of that so quite a
bit better in that regard
part of it may be the quality of the uh
the uh leads in here or the pins on on
the ac outlet there some kind of uh i
don't think they're gold but some kind
of coating on themselves a coating on
them and they feel nice and
the generic one of course you know the
standard sort of nickel plating or
whatever they have
so maybe i wasn't getting as good of a
connection again this is not material
because your socket in your ac outlet
and then all the wires behind it have
many times this kind of impedance in
kind of this resistance so your total dc
resistance is not you know this versus
this is uh you know i don't know 0.8
ohms compared to
0.078 ohms so
again in grand scheme thing doesn't
matter but you know i think it's fair to
give cred credit where it's due and you
know i was surprised how good this was
that only has 20 million
millions of uh resistance
um so every time i do tests like this
where you could just you know declare
the thing useless i actually sit back
and say all right what can i do
different
to test these products
in a more creative way and try to probe
and find out what's going on in this
case they talked about distortion i said
i i've never measured the distortion in
a ac power cord um let's see if we can
measure that so i set up my audio
precision analyzer programmed it to
produce 20 volts which is near its
maximum output as a substitutes for 120
volt
and then i told her to produce 60 hertz
which is the mains frequency we have and
then i told the audio precision to
shortest input to its output so it's
measuring itself so it's generating 60
hertz very quality is high quality 60
hertz and then it's measuring its own
distortion and noise and as you can see
it's just got impeccable specs despite
this voltage being quite high 20 volts
is able to still keep distortion down
synapt is 120 db so it's extremely good
uh uh response but again this is no wire
at all this is uh the input and up was
shorted with a relay internally to audio
precision
i then measured my generic chord
power chord same way um what i did was i
want to make sure this testing is clear
i took a generic the ac cord and treat
it as a signal cable so it's hooked up
to the input and output of the analyzer
it's not powering the analyzer it's not
powering anything
but it's being driven think of this as
the most pure ac signal you can get
compared to your regular ac which has
tons of distortion and noise um this ac
is 20 volts lower than mains but it's
exceptionally clean with this kind of
you know noise and distortion and so i
run that through it and if if audio
quest is right that regular cable adds
distortion then we should be able to see
it right because we're just you know
cable doesn't know that you're hooking
up domains or whatever anything goes in
comes out if those crystals have
friction and cause distortion we should
be able to see it in this test but we do
not the performance is the same it's
remarkable that a ac cable a generic one
a two meter acts almost as if you have
no cable it's got that high of a
fidelity with a sign out of 120 db yeah
a little bit more distortion and this
would come and go if i sat there it
would drift up and drift down so it's
not a perfect cable but even if we take
the worst case thing the peak is minus
130 db so your regular generic 3b cable
is that pure that it could be used as
the
signal cable for very very high
performance applications let alone for
mains where it's just carrying juice to
your equipment
so but let's switch now to the uh
audioquest nrg
uh x3 and we see the same thing these
things were again dancing up and down so
i wouldn't go by exact value of them but
uh essentially it performs the same same
synapse same distortion same 20 volts
and same 60 hertz so
the claim that this thing has lower
distortion i mean we're measuring down
to minus how does 60 decibel and we're
still not seeing any claims of you know
it producing less distortion and
or the regular generic
freebie cable having any source of
distortion um
they're imagining problems and
stating them as proof
if they have proof they should measure
it and showed us what distortion there
is with the generic generic cable versus
their cable uh if they don't know how to
measure distortion then they don't know
that it has less distortion and they
shouldn't advertise that so
on distortion front it's a complete bus
regular cable is phenomenally good why
because the cable length is short you
know six feet is not that long of a
cable and
you can drive pretty good signal quality
through
that length of cable okay so now
somebody may say whoa you just measure
the you know audio frequencies and in
these this test ends at 22 kilohertz
well that's all we can hear
but you know for grins and and let's uh
go ahead and test the maximum bandwidth
of my analyzer which is 1.2 megahertz so
now we're going 1 200 kilohertz you know
something like 60 times higher than
threshold of hearing and look over here
the two look identical yeah little
variations here and there uh you know
with energy actually looking a little
worse but that's just run to run
variations
we see there you know few uh
interference spikes in the in the cable
same in both of them
so it's down to the most minute
signature of the uh the signal they're
identical
neither one of them is is
showing anything any distortion products
way past here that is not in the other
one is same
characteristics in both cables down to
minus
excuse me minus 130 db
so
it you just can't make a claim that this
one cable is better than the other one
based on noise and distortion
both of which are being measured in here
so that's a bust as well
now
the other test i usually run is to see
how susceptible cables are to uh picking
up interference magnetic interference uh
in this case it's a silly test in that
if these cables pick up 60hz that's the
power you actually want to produce
so
but you can think of it in reverse in
that if i can induce 60 hertz and
harmonics into a cable that means it can
also radiate
60 hertz just as well so i set up the
audio precision analyzer this time to
generate one kilohertz just to have a
signal that is not 60 hertz so we can
see the contributions so first i started
with a generic cable and i took a
transformer
it's the uh transformer for my linear
power supply that powers my grass
instrument that i use for headphone
measurements use uh powerster it's
preamplifier so i
set up a constant situation where the
cable was draped the same way and i put
the cable uh transformer on it and
wiggled around till i got the worst case
interference with the generic cable and
the worst case is minus 130 db for 60
hertz then it's got the third harmonic
and and so on that's just you know going
out past that um then i did the same
thing with the audio quest in our g3 and
you can see the signatures to say so yes
yeah i'm going to place it a little
differently than i did with this one
because geometry of the cable and
jacketing is different but you can see
that i was able to induce similar kind
of interference so as far as i'm
concerned both of them generate the same
kind of interference pattern and keep
your signal cables away from it or
across at 90 degrees
in general but you know our desirable no
even in the worst case situation the the
peaks are at -125 db so even if this was
coming out of your speaker you wouldn't
hear it in this case is the ac cable
having to
go inside the equipment which then
filters it anyway so
um not a concern but again
you know a bust as far as showing that
the uh audio quest is is better cable
now all of this was sort of appetizer
for the real test which is you know
again as i keep saying like a broken
record you don't listen to uh
an ac cable ac signal you listen to an
audio equipment so let's see if the
audio equipment uh you know performance
changes i just measured this top in dx5
it has an internal
power supply so i thought what the heck
i'll just use this as a random example
not anything hand-picked and i first
measure is performance and it's as good
as i report a few days ago so it's
distortion products are less than -130
db
uh you know you can see such small
details here we're able to pick up
little spikes in here down to minus 150
db
this just incredible amount of
resolution our measurements have and we
still can't see
uh you know
we can't see any contribution from mains
look how clean the mains response is in
here there's none of that those the
interference that i showed you
but maybe this gets clean if we power it
with the audio quest cable and of course
it it does not um same two distortion
spikes are generated by the uh dac and
the same little wiggling tiny bits of
distortion are here they're all
functions of the uh
of the device itself and again nothing
you know disturb as far as mains is
concerned so everything else is
identical yes there's a little bit of
run to run variations and that's normal
if i just watch the device with one set
of cables this decimal place changes a
little bit
uh on this thing so
using a low power device that's probably
less than 50 watts or less than 20 watts
um the dac doesn't care so your source
component you know generic cable just as
good as anything else
um but you know let's see if there's any
contributions from that slightly lower
dc resistance and maybe it carries more
power
so i just tested this audiophonics um
stereo amplifier as well
and i went ahead and retested that with
the generic cable and then with the
audio quest cable and look at these two
graphs i mean they couldn't land on top
of each other any better they're just
identical amount of power identical
amount of distortion identical amount of
noise
and we're measuring
very deep in here minus 115 db
and so if there was a hair out of place
we'd see the difference and we
absolutely are not seeing a difference
the uh power amplifier one did not
produce more power again that's the
reason for that simple you got all the
other wires behind your uh
socket and and identity this you know
you don't need that kind of emphasis as
we call it
out of a
you know cable
so
in every direction we're probing we're
seeing that just it all points to the
same reliable outcome that we could have
predicted we could have just said it and
declared it and walked away why did i go
spend the nine on those hundred dollars
and run all these measurements it's
because it's good to have data you could
say it but the other side said whoa
there's some emi problems or one leaks
more
you know magnetic field and
and uh maybe one has better resistance
and that so we measured all of that next
time somebody says whoa you know these
aftermarket cables you know
sounded better because of this and this
and that the manufacturer says we've
proven that the manufacturers uh you
know featureless is bogus um if they're
not bogus they should have been backed
with measurements and if they weren't
before here's an invitation for your
quest to show us how to measure the
noise and distortion i'm happy to see
that happy to go replicate what they've
done and measure
now
stepping back though it's easy to just
be critical of this thing but you know
other than the ugliness of the it's on
this thing it is a flexible cable it
feels good and hundred dollars not a lot
of money i mean it's like
go to fast food place four times uh so
you know you if you bought something
that costs 100 bucks and you use it and
feels good every time you touch it you
know fine i mean i it's just you buying
it for other reasons which is better
feeling and uh
i wish it was better looking also it's
not but you know it feels better it has
a lower resistance uh the connectors
actually mating is pretty good um so it
has you know attributes that uh you
could choose that is worth a hundred
dollars uh so in this case
it is hard to just you know be overly
critical uh would i go buy it would i
use this right now i still wouldn't use
it i'm using their cables that everybody
else has and and by the way once or
twice i've gone to i had some issues and
i was like oh i wonder if this solves it
nothing i was getting some noise once
and uh i
you know how the whim i said well let me
try this uh i had some mains noise on an
analyzer and i put this in there made no
difference at all i use another
aftermarket cable i have no difference
at all turned out to be something silly
that i that i fixed um so
so but you know it's you didn't break
the bank now the problem is that this
company makes much more expensive cables
go to tens of thousands of those i think
power cables i think 20 30 000.
and uh if this is their reasoning to
make those kinds of cables and these are
the benefits they talk about
then it brings to doubt
you know the merits of those cables i
hope somebody sends them to me for
testing i love you guys but not
more than a hundred dollars of my own
money to go waste on cables like this
and uh you know shows that we're sincere
about this that i do go spend my own
money buy this stuff get real data and
find out if they do some good um before
somebody said did you go listen to it i
could listen and tell you some random
stuff about you know whether i heard a
difference or didn't hear a difference
know that that's just not the way the
world turns when i show you signals that
are below threshold of hearing
the measurements sometimes speak the
truth and say it so strongly that you
just don't dare saying well maybe
they're still like no when i'm showing
you mesh serpents with noise and
distortion they're just incredibly low
and the engineering principle behind it
says you can't make a difference the
fact that in a sighted test i could tell
you made a difference or didn't make a
difference it has no value a blind test
where you get a dozen people and run
them through trial 10 or 12 times
would be useful so anybody who says this
stuff doesn't count go ahead and do that
blind test turn on your camera on your
phone and go ahead and record and
produce that video and show it to us
the manufacturers have never produced
such a test no user that braves about
these cables has done that yet it's very
simple right you don't need me you don't
need my instrumentation you don't need
knowledge of measurements
take one cable plug it in and then plug
in the other one and randomize that
sequence and make sure the person
listening can't tell the difference do
it ten times you know might say oh maybe
i'll get stressed and i can't hear it
well
then that means the verse must be tiny
and it's certainly not this kind of
difference look at what the guy had
stereophile uh
talked about you know let me
uh oh we got a little big
um the reviewer that uh said the nrg3
delivered more music
well there's no such thing as more music
right you can right away say this is
nonsense and then he says made more
sense of the music
how do you make more sense of music
these are not technical terms these are
not proper descriptors for fidelity and
then it says manage to fully convey
artists intentions well you don't know
artists intentions you just listen to a
recording what the heck do you know
about artist intention did you call them
up did you send them the cable you know
this is all made up almost like a robot
wrote these things except it is a
reviewer at stereo file and unlike most
of the reviews that has the measurement
section so because sanity check it
this one did not have a measurement
section so
why didn't it have a measurement section
you know if the measurements are no good
for this how come they're good for
something else
so
you know this is how this stuff is sold
and you know any logical person should
step back and say that's that's not it
that's this stuff doesn't make any sense
how would an ac cable have control over
any of these attributes at all anyway uh
if it lowered the noise let's hear the
lower the noise and we can measure that
lower distortion okay we can measure
that uh but don't feed me stuff like
this in your conclusion that just makes
no sense at all on this thing
okay
uh so whoever asked for this review
hopefully you're satisfied uh i'll have
another after uh market cable a pangaea
that i can test a little bit more
expensive and much heavier duty than
this
i could test so maybe i'll do that in a
future video but for now um please don't
buy these cables because they think they
make equipment uh have higher fidelity
they cannot they do not and there's no
existence proof or such
okay see you in a future video bye bye